[Music]
house go Ambrose all right I don't
usually do this but this game is unlike
anything I have ever played before so I
just want to put out a little warning if
you are easily offended then please
don't watch this video it I don't even
know how to describe it but just I
promise you if you are easily offended
please please don't watch this video
that was pretty much it
for everyone else enjoy how's it gone
rose welcome to happy Hill my name is
Peter back I should know this is not
happy here if you wanted happy Hill I'm
sorry you're in the wrong place buddy
actually we sort of are in happy Hill if
you think about it but in the same time
we're not we're in this idea it depends
how you define happiness I suppose going
deep with PewDiePie anyway we're welcome
to eternal damnation it's a mob dafuck
idea of Postol to with weird and
background noise Asian this looks like a
hospital or something like a insane yep
we're at the hospital and I'm it's me
hey I'm just breakdancing
that's my breakdance I have no idea what
the [ __ ] is going on but that was a
beautiful night I better get the [ __ ]
away from my girl mouth all right I got
some action going on here wow that's
amazing oh that was a lot of stairs okay
I don't think he's very happy down there
or maybe yes maybe he did in my favor
you'll never know
oh wow that's splattered he said all
over the place I don't even know what to
say about this man it looks
oh he's insane oh it's just breakdancing
yeah yeah
Gaza moves there buddy yeah yeah all
right maybe we should take this
seriously after all ah
did someone punch my face is there an
invisible oh oh you like that you like
that and then with language that was but
it was something oh good mr. Murray
you're okay yeah I wanted to check up on
you I'm all good for pain all morning
he's going around the asylum killing
everybody
Oh No well he can't kill me I am a brig
taskmaster oh no he's right there buddy
okay yep he's going definitely going
around killing everyone I'm glad yeah I
don't even know what to say
that's pose that awesome ah I guess it's
in rigor mortis or whatever but still it
looks very funny okay you are out of
Healing Rooms let's go to the exit god
damn someone blank the exit well that is
my lucky why don't we get we have you're
out of using okay what is this I picked
up a badass outfit
yay I put on my sunglasses actually
that's what the [ __ ] I'm talk
yeah that's what I'm talking about
[ __ ]
yeah oh you got an F died in epic Pocius
- that's awesome
I'll be joining you too soon that's Rahm
[ __ ] talking about alright let's just
stay here and hacks computer all night
long I can't do that a flashlight would
be awesome or some sort of thing okay
there seems to be some action going on
here hey hey yeah yeah it's not
listening then never listen what about
you this is not creepy okay Oh nope hate
when you do that are you gonna move
again don't kill me okay it's just
people hey yeah why are you punching Oh
mother
I don't know how do i how do I punch I
lost my punchin abilities somewhere I
forgot how to punch how do I
I don't know what [ __ ] you did there
okay I can kick them at least come here
but just come the [ __ ] here [ __ ]
oh you think you're tough I just smack
that all on the floor smack that give me
some more [ __ ] [ __ ] or you better run
now who's your [ __ ] now [ __ ] [ __ ]
[ __ ] [ __ ] all right you're my [ __ ] -
oh don't think I forgot about you bet
all right ha ha this is awesome oh yeah
yeah yeah yeah I need to figure out like
a [ __ ] controls what is that
hahahaha there's a batch size my
hahahaha this game is the best game oh
[ __ ] god yeah yeah yeah
oh no I ran out of piss I pissed my
pants holy [ __ ] what the [ __ ] oh [ __ ] oh
no I'm pissing on now it's coming
everywhere oh that scared me too much oh
my [ __ ] god yes I got a feeling I
would love this boy oh my god alright
hey hey don't run away when I come talk
to you
hi what did I say eat it beat that
[ __ ] piss do it all night dog it yes
I told you to eat how am I even possible
I am very acrobatic
yes all right and now I just need to
figure out how I punch people
ah [ __ ] it I'll just keep them all right
I need to progress I think ha ha ha oh
my lord everywhere do you want to know
yes and one what a mouth before any one
of you want anyone wants me I got my
dick sounds I got my dick sound I got my
dick sound I got my deck side pissing on
everyone yeah yeah rainbow purse rainbow
pass yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah I
call this one the slaps piss I call this
one to piss under that bodies I piss on
you I'm gonna piss on you yeah let me
show that face I want to piss while
you're laying there in a very awkward
pose yeah yeah yeah passing all night
long
pissing in circles pissing everywhere
pissing everywhere oh now mrs. chant
what what are you doing pet it up piss
on me sorry she's great
oh I love the alright I think I need to
focus I'm sorry that that feature was
just too much for me alright maybe I can
jump in here no I can't alright we need
to think of something maybe he wants my
piss hey yeah do you want this alright
you'll exit definitely okay good I did
it was all on the favorite okay
hey how about you eat it ate my piss
back Yuto Yuto
we need the progress what about this can
you do anything about this
I don't know the controls I never play
this [ __ ] game before maybe I should
look at the controls options Contras
actions alright we got space QR q k
commit suicide alright yeah y'all get
down what the [ __ ] alright
unzip pants ah alright tapes down
[Music]
I'll never understand can we save you
here or something let's save it here
let's try the commit suicide thing I'll
try alright
press fire to end it all with my piss
[ __ ] nade in my mouth my god that's
the way how to do it
press 3 okay this game how are never
heard of this game before it's alright
that's just or something in your are the
feeling Athens
what about these employers only oh here
we go it is progress
that's nothing okay let's go here oh
[Music]
stop [ __ ] Gloria okay I just put my
penis in here alright yeah Oh Oh back
[ __ ] back off and taste my piss
yeah you better run yeah that's right
you better run you better up Oh who's
the [ __ ] now why are you running
it's it Spence you scared bro alright
that's enough of that I'm sorry I am so
[ __ ] immature I know what about this
do you want my piss I pissed for Wallace
it's no problem alright that's not
disturbing enough I don't know what's
more disturbing him or me haha alright
oh okay deaf deaf okay that's double
death okay I guess
[Music]
what are you looking at huh what are you
looking at
[Music]
I hope this video doesn't get flagged
it's not my fault it's the game all
right this one doesn't have a head so
I'm just gonna chillax um take it hey
exit that's lovely I'm just gonna oh wow
damn what kind of sick mother [ __ ]
would do this I don't know probably me
considering all [ __ ] oh it's me maniacs
killing everybody yeah yeah anybody
anybody
taste it taste it taste it taste it
taste it taste it taste it taste it -
dad ha ha I feel like I'm [ __ ] maniac
please taste it taste it taste it taste
it taste it taste it taste it taste it
taste it taste it taste it taste my pig
bit that's what you get barrels that's
what you [ __ ] get alright let's
proceed over here
I don't like corridors I don't like card
eyes very much but we have our
differences corridor I know it nope I'm
not pissing on that I might be some
little babies and I'm not pissing them
anything that sounds like that okay I'll
just give it a little squeeze
I don't need your healing items I'm
awesome at this game all right oh you
little [ __ ]
there you go okay what is this alright
seems very nice
seems very very beautiful all right I'm
just gonna you know hang out over here
Oh James that's lovely
I always wanted to have a house full of
change hang now okay something bad fishy
is going up there oh no oh this is gonna
be turn out into a gangbang piss your I
don't know what it the thing when you
like pig ears oh oh you better run you
better run you better run you better run
now come back no please please come back
understand oh there he is oh you gonna
get some girl alright alright I am gonna
end it here bro I hope you don't think
I'm oh my god that was probably the
weirdest video I ever made then I made
some pretty [ __ ] weird videos hope
you enjoyed like and favorite if you did
subscribe to come abroad today and I'll
see you tomorrow
thank you so much whoever suggested this
hell of a [ __ ] [ __ ] hey cuz
[Music]
Oh best be joking the best video get
forget that our did odd but
[Music]